et bien que ces dames c'est un très très
grand plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec
vous après deux ans d pandémie où nous
n'avions pas la possibilité de nous
serrer des bras des faire des bises et
d'être donc au dans la proximité et de
celle là donc je vais vous parler nous
sommes là pour évoquer pendant 18
minutes 000 un futur désirable d'alcine
villes dans lesquelles la proximité
serre est quelque chose qui deviendra
heureuse heureuse parce que
effectivement
on a imaginé avec mes équipes des
recherches à la sorbonne où je dirige
une chaire donc au mode de vie urbain
qui pourrait changer par rapport à ce
que nous avons connu pendant 70 ans
d'urbanisme pour lesquels ne nous a pas
demandé notre avis et dans lesquels nous
subissons les transports plutôt que
profiter des certaines vies et de la
chose la plus importante que nous avons
perdu des plus soixante dix ans le temps
utile que nous n'avons plus
j'appelle et ça il ya six ans n'avait le
des cardeurs puisqu'il y avait la coop
21 qui était la grande réunion mondiale
des états pour parler des comment nous
allions vers la neutralité carbone en
2050 pour réduire les émissions co2 pour
éviter les réchauffements climatiques et
pour laisser aux générations futures une
planète habitable et dans lesquels nous
pourrions alors continuer à vivre avant
que il ne soit pas trop tard cette
décadence d'un quart d'heure aujourd'hui
fait le tour du monde
parce que nous vivons aujourd'hui dans
des villes partout d'éléments de manière
majoritaire mais chacun d'eux des vous
qui êtes ici à rob est ainsi aujourd'hui
doivent chacun de nous devons répondre à
une question dans quelle ville nous
voulons vivre parce que des villes il ya
plein de manières différentes de faire
la vide débile moche des bulbes et des
villes avec des tours 2005 tour des
bills plate d'ebita les débiles compact
avec de la mer c'est la mer avec des
lots sans l'autre dans quelle ville on
veut vraiment continuer à vivre allons
nous continuer à subir la villetelle
comme nous est imposé où allez-vous
chacun de vous devenir un acteur des là
où vous habitez pour que ce soit quelque
chose qui ait un sens rapport à la vie
par rapport à l'acte dépassé dans cette
planète mais dans une période pas très
connu mais bref il est rare qu'ils
savaient pas centaines d'années pour les
plus fortunés je connais edgar morin qui
vient de le dépasser et je lui dis merci
edgar parce qu'edgar morin a éliminé mon
chemin sur la complexité de la ville qui
existait depuis 5000 ans avec plein des
civilisations la mésopotamie les empires
romain le père grec est bienvenu en
temps je viens de l'amérique latine donc
de thillois cannes les empires aztèque
il ya eu plein de manières d'y
construire des lieux dans lesquels nous
habitons et ça continue encore
aujourd'hui donc au des rêves des villes
de proximité il y en a eu plein super
premier à parler la ville de proximité
il ya eu plein de manières de faire des
vidéos proximité ceux ci
heureusement qu'elle n'a pas eu lieu
c'est le corbusier le corbusier qui a
créé la cité radieuse qu'on peut encore
visiter à marseille avec des modulateurs
espèce de
bâtiments dans lesquels on avait tout à
portée de la main mais sans jamais
sortir vers lesquels on était un peu un
fermé et les cowboys avaient imaginé
vous voyez paris qu'on pouvait raser
tout le quartier date en maîtres donc au
secteur là où chaque tour était un
module dans lesquels on pouvait habiter
travailler manger faire des courses et
heureusement que on a respecté la chose
la plus importante qui existe dans nos
villes c'est la considérer comme chacun
de vous qui respirait pour vivre qui
prenaient des l'air pur qui avait la
circulation sanguine qui avaient des os
solides des muscles pour vous porter
c'est ça la ville parce que la ville
vivante parce que la ville qu'on vous
ait là et métabolisme ce qu'est la ville
aussi il faut que leur inspire ce
qu'elle a vu aussi il faut que la
circulation sanguine son système nerveux
s'amuse toute la ville aussi il faut
qu'ils parlent mais ceux qui parlent
dans la ville c'est un ensemble
c'est vous c'est ce qui vous entoure
c'est la nature c'est ce qui est
construit mais il avait ce n'est pas les
constructions
non la ville c'est ce que nous en
faisons des ce qui a été construit et de
ce que nous allons continuer
à voir comme relation avec cette liste
mais aujourd'hui les choses ont
profondément changé nous sommes en 2021
il ya 2021 nous sommes maintenant à même
pas vingt neuf ans de cette échéance
fatidique 2050 mais déjà ça va pas du
tout et donc que j'ai dit effectivement
les villes concentrent aujourd'hui
énormément des problèmes c'est mon ami
rimer dernière à 6 mrd plus rétives à
qui a transformé sa ville au brésil et
qui disait les villes font partie du
problème mais etienne l'été des
solutions c'est pour ça que je suis
admirative de tous les maires du monde
qui s'est confronté à ça tous les jours
et je salue le maire de roubaix moulin
millions de delbard parce qu'il est
confronté tous les jours à roubaix comme
chacun des maires ailleurs à comment
affronter ces changements climatiques
qui est aujourd'hui présent tous les
jours et qui opposera les problèmes des
survies dramatique si nous avons une
température qui augmente comme c'est
déjà le cas au delà des 3 ° 1 sachant
que l'augmentation entre 1,5 et 3 degrés
sa rente doré c'est déjà une partie de
ce que nous connaissions habitable comme
inhabitable et cette inévitable qu'elle
soit inhabitable vous allez me dire que
c'est pas trés futur désirable que
c'était pas ça que vous étiez venus
entendre suis vraiment désolé suis
vraiment navré mais je ne suis pas
nicolas prologue ni pessimiste au log
donc que nous sommes l'un à
scientifiques chercheurs pour réfléchir
nous poser des questions nous interroger
et imaginer à celle que vous vouliez
venir voir ce soir peut-être un futur
désirable vous avez des belges disent
oui oui peut-être sont pas loin donc
nous nous sommes là aujourd'hui à se
poser la question si c'est oui lui sert
annoncé ravit donc qu on n'a pas le
choix nous devons sortir
d'amendé production consommation que
nous mène à la perte d'un peu partout
dans le monde métro boulot dodo tout le
monde les connaît plus de courses
ces images là ce sont en futur désira
voyons des huiles minérales des trafics
la circulation des transports des masses
des la consommation d'un des lieux dans
lesquelles on a perdu l'humanité
nous devons aujourd'hui nous poser parce
qu'il ya quelque chose de nouveau que
ses produits dans le monde entier 7
milliards 3,5 millions de habitants sur
cette planète les passagers de cette
planète est en danger ont eu une alerte
avec un virus qui fait 130 nanomètres un
nanomètre c'est un cheveu de la lune on
voulait me dis pas ça compte ça va pas
loin ça a paralysé la totalité de la
planète tout le monde était confiné tout
le monde était chez soir on n'a jamais
vendu autant des yaourtières n'a jamais
eu de jouer à autant scrabble on n'a
jamais autant vu nos enfants on n'a
jamais autant fait du pain des la maison
on n'a jamais autant pour la première
fois rencontrer les voisins pillards et
les voisins on a impliqué la dame en eau
elle par les espagnols ou italiens qui
est le gamin de la fin c'est le jouet
peut-être au au ballon on l'a découvert
des choses absolument incroyable
inventaire quand on tapait tous wouah ah
c'est toi qu'on vous dit rappelle david
roquet et toi moi mais delà à pedro oui
parce que là le doigt et s'appeler
mohamed rida et pedro qui allait dire la
dure je m'appelle carlos et donc on l'a
découvert qu'ils avaient effectivement
un monde qui existait certains l'on
appelle éléments d'eau d'après mes mots
je les crois pas que ça soit le monde
d'après je pense qu'il faut réfléchir au
monde d'aujourd'hui si on veut le rendre
désirable parce qu'ils ont sur le rendre
désirable dans 30 ans ça sera trop tard
donc le futur elle se construit
aujourd'hui
et notre défi dans chacune des villes où
nous sommes qu'elles soient des grandes
villes chinoises à 40 millions
d'habitants ok ça soit des villes
métropoles des moyennes villes des
petites villes des leurres oralité nous
avons tous une mission initiale nous ça
a été confiée retrouvez notre humanité
perdue
c'est ça qui est au coeur de nouvel
urbanisme pour lesquelles j'aime et bat
depuis des années avec mes équipes de
recherche et que nous préconisons
aujourd'hui partout le passons et nous
disons il ya urgence
il y à vraiment urgence à changer
des modes de vie des mondes peut-être
mais c'est plutôt le mode de vie et
cette urgence
elle est confrontée à un défi qu'on
n'avait jamais connu que très peu de
génération connu avant parce que
n'arrive même pas encore à une
génération c'est que nous sommes dans un
monde hyper connecté depuis les années
2000 quand nous avons connu la
révolution numérique
pourquoi notre mission votre mission de
monsieur le maire de vue les là c'est dé
retrouver notre humanité dans un monde
hyper connecté c'est là où ça se
complique c'est là où ça se complique
parce que le monde est venu manger
regardons urbain on habite aujourd'hui
dans des villes mais également nous
sommes hyperconnectés chaque personne
dispose de en deux trois quatre cinq
appareils collectés et donc nous avons
perdu cette capacité à voir le monde
avec nos yeux on voit les monts de
travers dans lentilles et on voit pas le
monde vous avez en l'antique pauvert le
monde on le voit que je te pleure
envoyer les photos surtout les
ressources tuque existe et on est
heureux parce qu'il y en a plein des
gens qui ont les quais où le compte de
tel à 8 ans des jo qu'il ait dont
absolument rien à [ __ ] ce que le verra
jamais on ne connaîtra pas et cela ne
représente pas l'humanité
donc cette urgence à retrouver
l'humanité de cette vieille dame
à lutter contre ces fléaux du 21ème
siècle qui et les zombies geek les geeks
hyper connectés et son be parce que
socialement déconnecter les sociale les
sociales sont bi des gens qui vivent
socialement mais tu sens totalement
déconnecté on le voit avec des cinq
vagues sont les voix avec la terre est
plate on le voit avec les créationnistes
peu près tous assumer mais vous il n'est
pas possible que des gens qui raconte
des bêtises mettait en danger beaucoup
des gens reçoivent passer une journée
500000 vue mais moi que j'ai fait un
petit poste que je l'écris et que j'ai
vingt cinq mille vue on dit ou super
content on a diffusé des choses
intéressantes 700 bus pour des intérêts
dans des réseaux sociaux donc
ok le mouv jetta les importants auxquels
les pertes auditives de était là grâce à
ça on va à plein d'endroits ça jamais
dire rien à personne parce que je suis
un truc qu'on arrive à au colisée
parfaitement sans problème j'ai eu
besoin de parler à personne
avant il fallait que j'aie demande de
madame savait où sept colis 0 b1 la
première à droite à gauche souvent voilà
c'était pas tout à fait ça mais bon là
parfois discutés voilà mais nous avons
besoin donc de comprendre cette
technologie se comme la fable d'esope
comme la langue cuisinier fait moi les
meilleurs plats il a fait de la langue
fait moi ton pire de playa n'est
l'ennemi il a fait de la langue voilà
c'est pour le meilleur et pour le pire
c'est juste un outil c'est par françois
donc auquel et la france fois comme moi
je les dis haut et fort il y aura pas de
nouvelle normalité s'il ne rateront pas
nos proximité seraient ils ont pas
bonjour à quelqu'un parce qu'elle garde
laurent une fois je l'invité et il a dit
dire bonjour à quelqu'un c'est le dire
tu existes ça se fait pas au travers à
ce mardi donc retrouvons de proximité
pour que moi soit l'autre et pour que
l'autre soit moi
ses graphismes en anglais mais oui nous
devons d'être informé de cette altérité
dans cette empathie c'est dans nos
villes on retrouve aujourd'hui de
l'exclusion la haine de la violence si
un éditorialiste occupent les chaînes
pour dire du mal de l'autre parce
qu'elle s'appelle - bailout parce que sa
couleur au sein des régions ça leur
convient pas c'est parce que nous sommes
en train de perdre le lien social qui
nous avons envie que tout et qu'il est
donc urgent de retrouver ses proximités
c'est pour ça que nous avons inventé
cette nouvelle sociabilité urbaine que
nous appellons laver des quarts d'heure
pour les zones très denses et les
territoires dès la demi-heure pour les
hommes donc au moyennement denses et aux
faibles monde danse on appelle ça une
nouvelle circularité nous connaissons
tous d'économie circulaire et rober est
à la pointe mais nous voulons aller
encore plus loin nous voulons que les
cirques vérité soit la manière comme
nous vivons pour que l effet d habiter
des travail et des faire nos courses de
nous soigner d'apprendre des nous
épanouir soir est lié par un ensemble
qui nous permet alors d'epargne est une
ressource fragile de nature nous permet
de créer de la valeur économique pour
lutter pour l'emploi et contre la
pauvreté décret et de l'impact social
pour lutter contre l'exclusion les
racismes la démagogie pour que les liens
avec et l'autre permettent des red sonné
à l'homme la part noble sa lumière celle
de l'humanité c'est ça que nous
appellons la ville du quart d'heure la
ville du quart d'heure cède ainsi zone
compacte accéder à ces choses-là habiter
travailler
m'approvisionner mais soigné mais
cultiver et me prélasser et nous disons
ça pour éviter notre l'ennemi commun à
tous ces longs trajets pendulaires qui
dure une eau ou plus à l'aller et autant
au retour et que nous coupe des landes
rôle aux habitants qui nous a mis dans
des lieux que nous utilisons que dans la
journée que nous amène donc au 1 n'est
pas savoir donc au avec qui nous sommes
dans un quartier où nous habitons et qui
nous amène à à perdre donc au cette
qualité de vie qui est la seule chose
qui doit compter quand on habite quelque
part c'est pour ça que nous disons qu'il
ya trois éléments de bien-être que nous
devons protéger avant tout mon bien-être
personnel avec ma famille vit look avec
des gens que j'aime parce qu'elle va
retrouver de l'amour sinon
nous perdons notre droit de tirage dans
les passages sur cette planète
nous devons retrouver la sociabilité
avec nos amis avec mon voisin avec mes
collègues de travail et le devoir
retrouver également des reste qu'au
logique au quotidien
pour que on protège la nature et
l'altérité par rapport aux gens que je
connais pas
nous appellons donko les maires nous
appellons tous ceux qui ont des
responsabilités
nous appellons les entreprises des
secteurs privés les citoyens à mettre en
exergue le bien commun
comme tout ce qui peut protéger avec des
ressources matérielles et immatérielles
pour sortir certains aspects essentiels
à notre bien-être dean économie
spéculative et pour offrir la capacité à
qu'elle s'assoit à la portée de tous et
chacun
ce n'est pas les 15 minutes pour moi et
ma famille donc ont des manières
ségrégative au contraire sa lutte est
contraint des villes qui sont devenus
aujourd'hui depuis soixante dix ans par
la manière de produire et consommer
ségrégative dans lesquels on s'isole
dans laquelle les quartiers évident le
soir un vieux est prêt et dans la
journée mais a mais seul le soir donc on
appelle ça une ville police entre
équipes ville molly multicentrique et
ville services qu'elles évitent dans
lesquelles il ya la ville partout nous
appelons ça la forme de la ville dé
proximité et heureuse pour vivre plus
intensément est pourvue vrai mieux vous
savez qu'un bâtiment que vous utilisez
il n'est certes qu'un trait 30 et 40 %
de son temps ça veut dire qu'un trait 60
et 70 % de son temps il est vide
arrêtons ces gaspillages la circularité
pour tout ce qui fait partie de la vie
la manière d'y habiter de travail et des
affaires se court sur des trains forme d
apprendre l'espagnol pour que les
bien-être la sociabilité et yvelines est
inclusive soit vraiment au rendez vous
réinventons nous voisinage dans toute la
ville
c'est possible il ya plein de gens qui
les font ailleurs aussi parce que ils
obéissent à une autre manière aussi des
fonctionner mais nous sommes aussi
aujourd'hui dans cette voie là ça c'est
le nouveau quartier donc du traict dans
les pays bas ça c'est la guerre des
huttes rect donc au fait pour les multi
modalité et les vélos ça c'est un
valencia où aujourd'hui une autoroute
devient un grand parc ça c'est à vienne
en autriche où nous avons aujourd'hui
donc de rue qui sont complètement
apaisées avec une proximité qui
s'insultent yves je suis très fier des
projets avec mon ami du cp salah les
nerfs 2001 non à place alors état qui
est devenu sa des lieux de vie dans
lesquelles elle a la capacité de bouger
avec des moyens des carbo les paris qui
a récupéré donc que cette proximité le
rue des écoles parce que j'ai entendu
quelqu'un parlait tout à l'heure des
rues deux écoles donc à roubaix et donc
je lui fais un clin d'oeil et il sert
connaîtra donc au new york on ne voyait
pas c'est transformé donc un broadway
copenhague et nous ça c'est une piste de
ski au dessus d une usine d'incinération
on récupère donc au lait chaud et on les
fait contre lyon but en effet passé et
un piste des skis et des immeubles dans
lesquels tous tout le monde ces
rencontres medellin donc que la terre la
mer devenue aujourd'hui après une ville
de violences quelque chose qui les sert
à tout le monde parlait metrocable les
nouvelles proximités c'est ça s'est
transformé les lieux pour que certes
plusieurs choses c'est londres ou six
étages de parkings souterrains devenus
aujourd'hui des lieux de vie voilà
roubaix aussi se transforme j'ai
remercié les maires sous l'équipe qui
s'impliquent c'est pas un achat d'une
courbe de tête mais je me permets de le
dire parce que vous aussi vous avez doit
répondre à évident et qu'elle voulait
vivre avec des l'écologie de la
solidarité de la participation et de la
proximité merci
[Applaudissements]